pour l'actualité de ce mercredi matin
reste d'abord tournés vers amiens où le
préfet de la somme avoué hier soir avoir
été trompé par un rapport des crs sur
l'origine des incidents du week-end
entre jeunes d'une cité harkis et la
police je vous rappelle en deux mots la
faire sur la foi d'un rapport des
policiers le préfet avait d'abord assuré
qu'il n'y avait eu aucune intervention
des crs samedi soir dans un local où
avait lieu un anniversaire hier une
bande vidéo amateur est venue dû prouver
exactement le contraire carlino draps
jacques garnich enquête nous donner aux
familles de leur vaut ces logements
devront déjouer les pièges question de
soulagement ce matin à l'institut de la
briqueterie car depuis le début des
événements ils étaient nombreux à
dénoncer l'attitude des faits restent
dans la cité a protesté contre
l'intervention d'une demi brigade samedi
soir lors d'une fête organisée par les
plus jeunes du quartier
et lorsqu'ils sont allés ce perdre en
début de semaine à la préfecture
personne ne les a crus j'ai entendu dire
je dois dire sur la présence et la
soi-disant les actions des crs beaucoup
de d'accusation qui me paraissent
relever du roman pure et simple
il a fallu ce film amateur d'un habitant
du quartier pour prouver l'intervention
des crs
le document permet d'entendre
l'explosion des bombes lacrymogènes et
de voir les jeunes évacués le local
devant les forces de l'ordre
[Musique]
c'est avec ce document sous le bras que
les mères de famille bien décidés à se
faire entendre ont rencontré le préfet
difficile alors de ne pas reconnaître
l'intervention des crs
apparemment sans raison et dans des
conditions qui sont parfaitement
contraire aux instructions qu'ils
avaient quand vous avez réagi tôt au
début puis la colère l'incompréhension
extrêmement choquée extrêmement chaud
les propos du préfet ont été ressentis
comme quoi au moins pour une fois on
reconnaissait la vérité quoi parce que à
croire qu'il vit dans un autre monde
mais se rendait pas compte de la réalité
moi déjà plusieurs reprises j'avais déjà
dit à la préfecture j'avais déjà dit aux
autorités ce qui se passait avec les crs
qui se passe avec les autorités
policières et tout sur le quartier au
niveau de la justice et on croyait qu'on
parlait à un mur le quartier ce matin
retrouver des allures paisible les trois
personnes mises en garde à vue ont été
relâchées et l'incité fois depuis hier
un héros le cinéaste amateur
oui à l'instant même le secrétaire
général du syndicat indépendant de la
police nationale a publié un communiqué
dans lequel il estime il lui apparaît à
lui en tout cas
impensable que des crs est agi de leur
propre initiative faut savoir que cette
compagnie de crs a été relevé expédie
dans une autre région de france depuis
ces incidents
[Musique]